I really liked him and I trusted him and
I thought that he had a unique way into
this character and into this world so it
felt pretty confident of that I think I
just was probably unsure of myself
summer's over Halloween is creeping up
the Joker is right on time and it looks
like we're finally getting a backstory
for this infamous DC character here's
everything you need to know before you
go
[Music]
Joker has been around for ages loved and
loathed by DC comic fans all over the
world we were first introduced to him in
April 1940 he appeared in the Batman
series by DC Comics as the superheros
arch-nemesis a quick Google search will
tell you that the Clown Prince of Crime
has been played by over 20 actors
spanning film TV and animated series fun
fact in the original comic book it was
planned for the Joker to die but
ultimately they decided to continue as
narrative making him Batman's
long-standing foe let's crack into the
most popular Joker's in this deck of
movies you get what I was trying to do
right so we've got Cesar Romero the
court jester must run just in time Heath
Ledger introduced a little NRK Jack
Nicholson ever danced with the devil in
the pale moonlight Mark Hamill you're
going to melt just like a grilled cheese
sandwich
Cameron Moynihan call me jack sorry
Joseph John Jay no and Jared Leto the
average person might have thought Jared
Leto would star in this standalone Joker
film but this new Joker breaks away from
letõs portrayal having nothing to do
with the already established DC Universe
director Todd Phillips has said that the
inspiration for Joaquin's Joker was
drawn from various comics and not rooted
in one specific story I think the fun
thing about writing this movie was
basically figuring out how to run
everything that we know of Joker through
as realistic a lens as possible why does
he have this laughs before I read the
script Todd showed me videos of people
that have this uncontrollable laughing
Fitz
one in particular who it looked very
painful is basically get read and he
you would choke and so that was the
inspiration I really I just tried to
copy copy them so let's explore this new
Joker's world this version of the story
is about a troubled man balancing his
days as a paid for a higher clown while
pursuing a career as a stand-up comedian
you don't listen do you came to me and
he was like what if we just play him
like dovey and heavy I said no I think
it's really important that Arthur kind
of looks and feels like wolf-like
something like malnourished and hungry
although I didn't expect him to lose
that much in fairness he just went with
it in this iteration the clown living on
the fringe of society is named Arthur
Fleck the film remains true to the
characters origin in that Fleck is
living in Gotham City the fictional
place reminiscent of New York and
Chicago
Arthur flex journey and rise to crime
lords status is set in the 80s this
snippet of Robert De Niro's role as
Murray Franklin a talk-show host
pushes that nostalgia when I was a
little boy and told people I was gonna
be a comedian everyone laughed at me
well no one's laughing now it's not only
King of Comedy to be fair it's it's
really a time period of movies mid 70s
to early eighties kind of these great
character studies I did actually send
the script of it to morons for Sadie
which was a trip in itself and he read
it and we had a nice great phone call
the rest of the cast includes the
lovelies as he beats who plays Sophie du
monde Sophie and Arthur share a kiss in
the trailer are we looking at the next
Harley Quinn Marc Maron is also in it he
appears this ted marco a producer on De
Niro's talk-show in the film and
director Todd Phillips teamed up with
multi-talented actor director Bradley
Cooper to produce prior to Joker
Phillips was known for his comedic tone
in films like The Hangover up which
Bradley starred in pretty cool and
interesting these two got together for
this dramatic take on a comic book
I saw it as a really um kind of fun
sandbox to go into and try something
really different with which is what we
did with Joker it's not that now I want
to make other comic book movies and
again not that I wouldn't and would you
believe that Oscar buzz is already
circulating around Joaquin Phoenix's
performance the movie isn't even out yet
what do you think about that Joker
premiered at the 76th Venice
International Film Festival this summer
and received an eight-minute standing
ovation from its audience it won the
Golden Lion award the festival's highest
prize I think I always go through a long
process with deciding if I'm gonna make
a movie or not and I guess it's just
like wanting to be sure or at least as
close to shore as possible that you want
to take on the experience so how well do
you think this will do opening weekend
do we have to worry about the resurgence
of this Halloween costume my heart can't
take it which Joker is your favorite huh
Mark Hamill huh so now you know and now
you can go see Joker in theaters October
4th
[Music]